so what were you like in high school as
a high school kid there was probably an
indicator of of where your life was
going to go
right uh yeah I think I actually ended
up going the opposite way despite
everybody's disbelief but yeah meaning
what everyone wanted you to do something
I was a really bad kid and um life
turned out pretty
good you're 32 mhm and
uh you you've
the majority of your money came from
Vegas from casinos
yeah yeah did you start with a nest EG
or money or family money or anything uh
so I was born into an affluent family
but I made every wrong decision along
the way half of them were conscious
decisions the other half were just a
byproduct of the choices I was making
and I was homeless for a long time
incarcerated and um started with nothing
I had moved to the Miami area and I was
a day laborer I got a job for $100 a day
and um one thing led to another and I
saved up every penny and I started a
business and the business started to do
well started to grow I opened up a
couple more and the businesses did do
well I sold them and retired in my mid
20s moved to Los Angeles and when I
moved to LA I'd go to Vegas Weekly just
to gamble and have a good time and I
started winning I started winning a lot
started winning often where you winning
everyone goes to Vegas to lose yeah I
mean gambling's like been embedded in my
blood for many generations I grew up in
New York City card rooms I've been a
gambler my whole life my whole family
has and so I'd say I was always like
slightly above average as a gambler but
in the beginning I was just winning I
don't know maybe I was lucky and the
more I was
winning the more I thought I should pay
attention to what I had going on and I
started buying in a little bigger
winning a little bigger and really
focusing all my energy on how to be a
better Gambler I ended up figuring out
that the casinos cheat they cheat in
ways that most people are unaware of and
I reversed their cheats and I became one
of Vegas's biggest winners of all time
so that's how you did it you figured out
what they were yeah doing behind
people's backs and you out out you
outdid them yeah how long did that go on
uh it took three years of gambling
specifically in Las Vegas before I got
banned from 95% of the casinos in the
world how do they ban you it came in all
different ways uh some of them made up
crazy stories uh some of them told me
outright um but they came in all ways
they would uh either confront me in
person they would call me over the phone
they would send me an email um a lot of
casinos don't reach out to me and say
hey don't come into our doors they'll
wait till I show up it'll be the first
time I ever came to that particular
casino and when I get there I get met
with security and they
go uh you're a sharp player you're an
advantage player and we're not going to
take your business that's IL legal yeah
it's a private company they can do
whatever they want
unfortunately little unfair or unjust in
my opinion you know but they might as
well just have a sign that says only
accepting
losers and you're not a loser no I won
pretty good how much do you think you
won uh it was calculated something in
the realm of $32 million really yeah in
in three years yeah wow and that's just
from specifically the Las Vegas casinos
I
play um a lot of games in private
settings as
well and you you hit all the big casinos
or yeah all of them so you go one and
get your youd recognize you and you'd
have to go another one yeah uh in the
beginning they thought that it's
impossible unless I'm cheating so they
go he's just hot right now he's lucky
keep him coming back give him a private
jet give him the Rolls-Royce give him
the Maybach you know keep him happy and
eventually he'll lose it all back and
then some and slowly they go well he's
not losing it back so he must be
cheating we got to keep what was your
game my I'm I won the most amount of
money playing bakarat but it's probably
only because they let me bet the most
they let me bet a quarter million doll a
hand in bakarat where Blackjack they
only let me bet 75,000 what are the
limits in bakarat normally 20,000 20,000
so they let you go higher they let me go
to 250,000 yeah hoping that you would
lose quick yeah lose bigger faster and
harder but I just I won more faster and
harder
yeah what's it like when you at the end
of the night and you you've walked away
with how much in the night so it
averaged out not for the whole three
years but for quite some time almost to
a million dollars a week but it didn't
it didn't look like once a week I'd show
up win a million and leave when we
became playing in the in the millions if
when that became our buyin and cash outs
what we were really doing was we'd come
in and we'd play and my average Buy in
was $3 million and and I'd put front
money deposit of 3 million either cash
like $100 bills or cashier check and for
the 3 million i' had negotiations for a
lot of things including my betting
limits when we would play let's say we
won 3 million that week profit I
wouldn't come back for three weeks some
weeks I'd win 5 million and then not
come back for five weeks I'd win 10
million not come back for 10 weeks two
weeks uh 2 million not come back for two
weeks so it average out to be about a
million a
week wow so what kind of what kind of
excuses would the different casinos use
to get rid of you so um one Casino has a
like super private super high roller
room on the second floor it's called the
Talon club and in the Talon Club it's
very quiet which I like it's quiet it's
private no one can watch and um they
have a a lounge on the side in the
lounge they offer like you know free
food and sitting and whatever and uh
they threw me out and they told me it's
because I touched too many Forks in the
talent
club that was you that's that was got
you kicked out yeah so they were I gave
them cash and they I when you buy chips
at the cage they run all the cash there
but it was a lot of cash so it took them
a little while to count it but you can
see that cage from the talent Club
Lounge so I'm in the lounge getting food
and I just pop my head into the hallway
and look to see if they're almost done
running the cash so I kept doing that
back and forth and security came and
said that I touched too many forks and
that I'm trespassed from their property
and you were all the big casinos I'm
sure yeah and uh one Casino uh one
Casino told me that I scared a Pit Boss
and for that reason they have to ban me
another casino told me that I had a
fight with the valet except that during
the time of the alleged event I wasn't
even in the state of Nevada so I came to
Nevada later that night I went to Vegas
and I went to the valet uh manager who
knows me and I said I said hey do you
mind if I record a conversation and he
said go ahead and so I started recording
I said hey there's like a an allegation
that you and I had a fight earlier in
the day is any of this true and he goes
I haven't seen you in weeks and I knew
it wasn't true like I said I wasn't even
in the state at the time of the alleged
incident and uh when I sent the video
over to the executive uh they just
stopped communication with me yeah I
mean those those big casinos run the
city run so they're they can do and say
anything they want some of them don't
have to give me a reason uh one of them
didn't the vice president called me and
he just said stop coming in is there
something about your personality
that makes this possible or makes makes
you likely to have figur F this out yeah
I think uh I think part of my upbringing
or my history attributes to some of the
characteristics that became applicable
during my discovery of the cheating and
how to reverse engineer it um I had I I
made a lot of those decisions away from
like the support of my family when I was
on my own I was homeless pretty young
and I incarcerated pretty young and I've
lived on my own for a long time and I
think from that kind of Lifestyle I saw
every type of con and cheat and steel
that exists you know in in every nook
and cranny of every type of street and
uh from that I just saw things that I
think these like suit wearing slicked
hair you know dressing guys weren't
prepared for me to understand or
recognize and probably on a level Way
Beyond
them and I was also um I was also
brought up my whole life um in some
association with the Italian mafia
and gambling was so thick around me that
the development of games were developed
by a lot of the maid men that I knew as
a child so it was a pretty open
discussion about the capabilities of
what casinos and casino Technologies can
do so is your view that the world is
kind of rigged and and you just have to
figure out a smarter hustle SM I think
100% I think you can either choose to
oblige to the game that they set the
rules to or you can fight against it but
when you fight against it you're going
to be met with with an equal an equal
and opposite
Force yeah so so now you're at a point
where you're financially secure you
don't need to make millions a week sure
but I wouldn't turn it down if an
opportunity came sure no of course but
what are you doing with your time
now uh I'm in a lot of TV shows and
movies now I spent a lot of time um in
the Hollywood scene uh creating and
producing even more shows than I'm in
and I've been really enjoying
that um I spent a lot of time teaching
people how to gamble that became like a
thing when I as I started getting banned
from the casinos uh at a pure boredom
during the pandemic I started social
media and I went pretty viral pretty
quickly um I started getting picked up
by a lot of hip-hop artists and
Hip-Hop focused channels and asking me
to like you know give advice or be
around and in the beginning I thought it
was so cool because these are some like
my childhood Heroes like sliding in my
DMs like hey can I fly you to Vegas or
hey I'm in LA come to my birthday party
or whatever it is and um so a lot of
them were like Hey we're going to Vegas
we have new money we're lighting the
money on fire on the tables we get our
appearance fee for a concert and then we
turn immediately and the show's done and
just lose the money do you want to come
with us and maybe help us mitigate some
of the losses you know give us a chance
to win and so I said yeah I would do
that so I started teaching um a lot
of um people how to play and beat the
casinos and then that became a bit of an
issue too so what I do now is um I
gamble under the guise of unknown
gamblers I fund 100% of their betting so
they have no exposure or liability to a
loss and I give them a piece of all the
earnings we split all the profit and uh
I promote it through my Instagram
there's like a link you just like fill
out the link it's pretty simple there's
a very heavy vetting and
qualifying uh process but if you meet
the requirements I fund all you're
betting and we split the profits you you
figure you figure out hustles that are
yeah I want to beat the you know I plan
I'm a I'm a professional Gambler and I'm
going to gamble and I'm going to win is
there is there something about risk and
the adrenaline that this all brings that
is your your that's your drug um I don't
know I think I see a lot of this as a
game and uh I'm very competitive I like
to
win so even when they think that I'm not
allowed to be in the race anymore I
still find a way to get a winning
winning horse in it you
know yeah you're you're not going to be
kept down they can try what's your
biggest
fear my biggest fear is not being liked
not being wanted or accepted and that
all this in life was for nothing I mean
is is there meaning in your life or I
mean because you know gamblers I I've
always looked at professional gamblers
is like what an empty existence they're
not they're not contributing anything to
the world they're just kind of like
they're good at gambling and that's
that's a great skill But ultimately
their lives are empty pretty empty it
seems I don't disagree
[Music]
um I do a lot to give back I uh I built
a school uh K through 8th grade I am one
of a particular kad's biggest donors I
built a
synagogue
um when I die the majority of my estate
will be donated to charity specifically
the Innocence Project
I would say I do what I can to live a
fulfilling or wholesome life uh every
trip I take to Vegas I go to the
underground city and I feed the Homeless
and these might be small things or maybe
in comparison even big things some of
these are big things I'm not sure how
much of a dent those things will really
make I just know that the more energy I
put towards it it could only be a good
thing even if it's on a small scale and
I try my hardest um I also discourage
gambling I think gambling is a very
sinful dirty evil world to live in and
um I agree but I but I could also say
that or we could say that about any
profession even outside of gambling you
know talk about a banker it's the most
uh simple plain job what are they doing
to be fulfilling or give back yep I
don't know i' I'd agree with that the uh
those good deeds that you're
doing impact your self-worth your self
your self-image it makes everything
you're doing the lifestyle you're
leading kind of okay in your mind
right I would
say out of the people that I know in my
position I probably do more wholesome
Pure or selfless things than the
majority of them and I think that allows
me to justify a lot of
my inappropriate or selfish or self
self-seeking
behaviors yeah you're you're a bad boy
and a good boy at the same time I do my
best to stay on the good boy side do you
have any regrets oh man a whole ton of
them what are You' probably have a lot
of regrets yeah I would start by saying
one of my bigger regrets is getting
tattooed uh I've been removing my
tattoos for five years I'm going to
continue to do so you think I look crazy
now you should have see what I used to
look like before I cleaned up my ACT oh
really yeah um I
regret um not being better to my parents
when I was a kid I
regret not going to school I
regret hurting people I regret the
crimes stuff like that how far did you
go to
school I didn't um in 10th Grade I went
to juvenile prison for a while and never
really went back I um taught myself uh
and took the G my GED and SATs while
incarcerated I did pass my GED um I
while still incarcerated I was on a
parole violation and I applied to five
universities and I got accepted to all
five of them they didn't know that I was
in um State Facility what I was doing
was I would send all the paperwork to my
grandfather's house he would repackage
it so the stampage came from a residence
not the Department of Corrections and he
would be the um the aggregate between
the universities and I and they did all
five accept me but I couldn't get
repared in
time do I mean do you think you'll be
living this lifestyle the rest of your
life I think every day something comes
up that changes the direction of my life
or my lifestyle and I think if you were
to look at my life a year ago in
comparison to what it is now it's almost
like two different people and nothing
drastically has changed in the last year
you know I just think as I go through
life and I find new Hobbies or new
interests or New Direction you know I
evolve around it you know for the
betterment of whatever my new goal is
and that makes your life Rich rather
than the money that you have enriched
yeah is risk a part of
your your philosophy here I mean you you
seem you're not risk averse uh I'm not
fearful of
risk yeah some of some of us see risk
as perfectly sensible and apprpriate in
most
situations um I feel
that from a lot of the dark stuff that
came in my past when I was younger I
feel like I faced such grave
consequences on so many occasions that
when I look at the risk reward factors
now the biggest risks I have today don't
even step into the realm of the risks I
used to take with no upside back then so
now it's like the the worst that I can
do is be better than the worst I was but
look at the look at the upside I can
have what was your childhood like that
kind of LED you down this path my super
young childhood was great I have great
parents always had great parents great
grandparents great family everything was
good as a very young child were you the
black sheep I was the black sheep yeah
um I did Sports I raced Motocross I was
an amateur Motocross Champion I um I did
a lot of great things and then
I started um I wouldn't use the word
rebelling because I wasn't rebelling
from
anything I don't know I just um just
didn't feel like this cookie cutter life
from the suburbs was the one I just
thought there was so much more and I
would just push any limit I can to see
like how far things in life can go and
it started pretty young I started
getting in trouble very
young and uh with when when you get in
trouble you get entered into a different
life with
different coping mechanisms and
different Lifestyles and different types
of people and the more trouble I got the
more the lifestyle around it evolved to
be darker and more
Sinister did your parents disapprove of
you at some point in your life yeah when
I
was I want to say 13 or 14 I was a
really tough kid to raise and my parents
again were so loving they still are and
they're great parents but I had just
rang them dry of all their resources and
they told me that they said hey like
we've tried everything that we can think
of and more we're incapable of giving
you the help you need at this point we
have to protect and save whatever piece
of the family is left and they gave up
the ability to raise me and I got passed
around quite a bit I would say I got
passed around more than my ex
did and um
whoever wanted to take a try raising me
tried and ultimately it was just
myself but at some point maybe 10 years
later or so you you you became a
different
person yeah when I was uh did your
parents see you differently
then no they didn't they didn't no
because my parents saw me since I was a
child and growing into like a teenager
and even like a young adult be a very
troubled person you know I was
incarcerated a lot and I was in trouble
a lot and I was like almost
unhelpable so how can even 10 years go
by with very little contact of me and I
call them and all of a sudden they're
like oh we believe you on the first
phone call that you're a different
person than we've known you to be your
entire life so a lot of years went by uh
of me just knowing that my
parents
are out of touch with me you know
straightening out and uh just carrying
on in the right direction because it was
best for me and it made me happy and it
was good for me and those around me the
changing moment with the relationship
with my parents
was uh I was winning something like six
or $9
million and I call my dad and I go hey
Dad I'd love to fly you to B Vegas you
know I just want you to see what I'm
about and I had tried explaining to him
when I was in business and I own these
companies I had flown him down to Miami
and I tried to tour take him on a tour
of all my offices and my warehouses and
I watched him just not really engaged it
was almost like too grandiose for him to
even come to terms with and he really
just sat on his phone and stayed in the
car we'd pull up like my headquarters
office I'm like Dad you want to come
inside I'm going to wrap some stuff up
he goes no I'm just going to wait in the
car and I was like I don't really get it
it's a little disheartening and
Discerning
but it was what it was and then uh fast
forward call it five years after that
and I'm in Vegas and I'm winning
whatever it was six or 9 million I don't
know at this particular moment I called
him I go D I want to fly you to Vegas I
just just always want to have you out
you know he goes all right no problem
when he lands on the plane uh he gets
picked up in a Maybach when the Maybach
arrives to the front door of the casino
the vice president had opened the door
and greeted him and said hi I'm so and
so and I'm the vice president and my
dad's looking I'm standing there my
dad's looking and he's a little confused
maybe but didn't fully process what was
happening and the vice president walks
my dad and I up to
my uh presidential suite it's like eight
bedrooms you know indoor pool two gyms
inside and it's just me and my dad and
there's Butlers in there when we walk in
and I I say you know we talk to the vice
president just for a second vice
president's like oh yeah you're you know
Mickey is this and your son is this and
all this and it's great to have you guys
and what have you and I ask everyone to
leave Butler's vice president everybody
it's just me and my dad and we start
talking and I'm seeing my dad looking
around the the suite and the villa and
he's like where are we you know and I go
we're in my room my hotel room what do
you mean and he goes what's going on
here why did the vice president meet me
why did I get picked up in a Maybach
what's happening I go well D I've been
trying to tell you you know for the last
quite some years I've been doing pretty
good in life and he wasn't really
grasping it and uh you go so what are
you doing this week that you have me in
Vegas and I go nothing I just wanted to
bring you out right now I'm up you know
however many millions and he goes what I
go yeah you know right now I'm winning
and again I forget six or 9 million
whatever it was and um he goes no way
and I go yeah yeah yeah for sure you
know I go I'm not done you know we're in
the middle of the week here but yeah so
far he doesn't believe it so I call the
vice president I said can you please
come back upstairs and the vice
president comes in and and I go can you
please tell my Dad how much I'm up on
this trip and he goes he's up $6 million
this trip my dad's like really and I go
can you please tell him how much I'm up
on the quarter and he goes on this
quarter he's up 15 million I can you
tell him how much how much I'm up for
the year and he goes well for the year
he's up you know 21 million and my D my
dad was speechless I said Thank you and
the VP walks away and my dad looks at me
and he goes I just don't get he goes I
don't get it what's happening I said let
me take you on a little tour and I took
my dad on a tour of what my life looked
like in Vegas I had um I was living in
the top floor of another building on the
strip and um there was maybe 200 or so
people in there it's the middle of the
day and they were just partying and the
way you would enter the Villa I was
living in in the other building is
there' be an elevator through a private
entrance and when you get into the
elevator which you can only get in with
my access it would go up one floor cuz
all this elevator served as an entryway
to my villa the door would open and that
was my front door and once the elevator
door opens you're now in my villa and I
had told uh some very famously
successful friends of mine that they can
use my villa that afternoon so they had
um 50 fully nude very attractive girls
surrounding the front door area CU they
were doing body paint and black tape on
their bodies cuz they wanted to use
these girls for a party they were going
to throw in my villa that night so the
door opens and I'm with my dad and he
sees all these incredibly attractive
naked girls and he just couldn't figure
out what was happening and um one of the
staff from the event came up to me the
the girl was just an employee she didn't
know who I was or anything like this and
she goes hey I'm sorry this is a private
uh location you can't be here and I go
no no I think it's okay I think I could
be here she goes do you know somebody
and I go yeah me this my spot and um
everybody came up and greeted me and my
dad got to witness all this and he spent
the week with me he actually flew his
business partner in just because he
couldn't believe his own eyes and his
business partner Pete came in and they
spent the week you know I gave him the
car I gave him the Maybach and I said
just enjoy yourselves I'm going to have
the driver take you wherever I think you
want to go and you'll be a part of the
party and you'll hang out with me and
I'll show you my life and ever since
then things have been different with my
family yeah I bet that'll make it dead
proud
yeah it's interesting the uh the the
lifestyle that you were leading or maybe
still am still are it you know tell me
about that because even the VP of the
casino you know deep down he's just
trying to get his money back yeah so
he's not he's not your buddy oh no I um
and the girls are there for what reason
yeah I was never fooled by the glamour
of Vegas I was never fooled um I think
I've like I said earlier like I've seen
so many cons and so many finesses and
when you grow up like in the street
culture and in the Underworld you see a
lot of these things happening
in in a weird level like um like on this
show I know you have a lot of people
that are um like sex workers for example
right now a lot of John's are like
pretty standard men right they live a
very mundane life and they're regular
guys and they work 9 to5 and they don't
see a lot of the underworld stuff but
behind that there's so many layers that
that sex worker and the sex workers
group is going through and utilizing to
extract the most amount of money from
the most amount of John's but to a John
they only see it at face value they
arrive they see an attractive woman
maybe the woman says a couple of words
and they have a transaction the JN has
no idea what took place behind that but
because I came from that life I've seen
every back end of every finesse and con
there was so when I entered the Vegas
world I said these lights don't fool me
I said I've seen all types of lights and
um I've seen all types of people and all
types of con artists and I knew right
away when it comes to the casino staff
what I was dealing
with I was taught by the mafia what was
happening I was taught by guys that
invented some of the tools that are used
in casinos to this day some of those
guys raised me when when I no longer was
with my own father a lot of those made
men took a hold of me as a young kid and
said we're going to help groom you and
and it's going to you know we're going
to teach you what we've learned now and
these were 40 50 and 60-year-old maid
men teaching a 15 16 17 18year old kid
and and continue to do so in what city
this was in Central Jersey uh I don't
want to say the name of the city but it
was in Central Jersey and then I moved
to New York City pretty young and I had
grown up in New York City and then I
moved to Miami and from Miami where I
lived eight years is when I moved to LA
in Los Angeles um La in Los Vegas yeah
without that upbringing you probably
wouldn't be the person you are today I
can't imagine I probably would have been
just like everybody else and there's no
shame in this but I probably just like
everyone else would have fell victim to
this Mirage of a con that Las Vegas is
it was built to take advantage of your
average working class person and if I
had been an average working-class person
I don't see how I would not have been
taken advant advantage of
equally so now you go about you go
through your life having all this
wealth and these people that are Hangers
On basically do you see through all that
yeah it's super easy to see through most
I can't say I don't get tricked
sometimes and I still don't learn
there'll be something new that comes up
a new this a new that a new style a new
angle that I have never seen before but
I have a theory about people I think
there's only x amount of types of people
and a couple of outliers and I think
within each tier of person you can have
you know the top of the tier the bottom
of the tier and I think really quickly
the first few moments you can see the
characteristics that would put one of
these any person in one of these people
categories and once you know a category
you're there in you know exactly how how
to address them and how to guard
yourself so it becomes really easy to
gauge people if you if you look through
this like mathematical scale what would
you say is your greatest
strength I think uh uh I would if I had
to say one and and I wouldn't
necessarily I have so many say that I
have so many great strengths or that I'm
so this or so that but it might just be
that I'm a little bit of a creative
thinker well you you think differently
you're not a not a conformist I'm not a
conform but that also is a double-edged
sword yeah always yeah you know there's
a lot of downside to that as well yes I
know that yeah where do you want to be
in uh 10
years I'd like to see myself in a lot of
movies um creating a lot of movies and
TV shows and acting in them the acting
part's been pretty fun so
far I'm not really sure exactly who are
who are your Heroes growing up who do
you look up
to was mostly a talent gangsters you
know I liked all like the really the the
infamous ones were always interesting to
me I just thought it was like you know
in a world that's built to prevent crime
to be that successful at crime you have
to be that successful of a person you
know I would say it's easier to be
successful following the law than it is
by going against the law and some of
these guys did such great feats as
criminals that imagine what they could
have done if they were
legitimate what was what was the the
best time of your life so far what's
what's been the most enjoyable period uh
I'm not
sure just winning all that money you
know when you're making you know
millions of a week no that's not it no
it wasn't
it there was a
time when I wasn't making
money and me and my two buddies and my
girlfriend we got a house together in
the middle of
nowhere and we spent just 9 months in in
this house just acting a fool um we had
like found like a little life hack and
like we weren't we didn't really have to
pay bills we have to worry about any of
that stuff we just got to live and we
were living as like big kids and we just
destroyed everything in our path and we
rode dirt bikes every day and just we
never knew what time it was we never
knew what day it was and for nine months
we just did anything we wanted it was a
lawless land and it was just really fun
it was an awesome time
sounds fun what what what what do you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
Mickey not
[Music]
sure I think
that I'm still learning every day and
I'm still looking for like the golden
answer to life and to my problems
and whatever um I guess do you have do
you have problems like everyone else has
problems people people will hear the
your wealth and be like oh my God this
guy's got no problems at all well it's
all different types of problems yeah and
I certainly have problems and I have all
types of problems and um some of my
problems are really big and really hard
to solve and some of them are unsolvable
and other problems that maybe some
people think are the biggest problem in
their lives could be solved by money but
when they solve that problem they don't
realize there's a bigger problem waiting
across across the way and the bigger
problem doesn't get solved with money
and when you have a problem that can't
get solved with money and you and all
your whole life was built about getting
money then you don't know how to solve
that problem and then you're in a real
bad
spot and and back to my question the
most important lesson you think you've
learned in your
life I'm not sure I think um the most
important lesson I
learned is that nobody really has your
best interest except for you if you need
something done you're going to have to
do it do it
yourself trust is hard to find even
those you
trust they you
can't you
can't even the people that you trust the
most you can't assume that they're so
prepared to consider every implication
of every piece of the future of a single
decision in your life that they will
make the right decision on your behalf
they can only make at best right
decision for your immediate
result
interesting all right Mickey Mays thank
you so much for sharing your story
thanks for having me I hope you live a
very interesting and fun life from here
on out it's been a good time so far
sounds like it thank you
man